marks at this point we will not take
questions sir please
good morning
I deeply regret the decision by the
Russian Federation to terminate the
implementation of the Black Sea
initiative
including the withdrawal of Russian
security guarantees for navigation in
the Northwestern part of the Black Sea
these initiatives has ensured the safe
passage of over 32 million metric tons
of food commodities from Ukrainian ports
and the world food program has shipped
more than 725 000 tons of support
Humanity to support humanitarian
operations relieving anger in some of
the hardest hit corners of the world
including Afghanistan the Horn of Africa
and Yemen
the Black Sea initiative
together with the memorandum of
understanding on facilitating exports of
Russian food products and fertilizers
have been a Lifeline for Global Food
security and the Beacon of Hope in a
troubled world
at the time when the producing and
production and availability of food is
being disrupted by conflict climate
change energy prices and more
disagreements have helped to reduce food
prices by over 23 percent since March
last year
with the decision to terminate the Black
Sea initiative
the Russian Federation also terminated
its commitment to and I quote
facilitate then embedded export of foods
and flower oil and fertilizers from
ukrainian-controlled Black Sea ports and
of course as expressed in paragraph 1 of
the memorandum of understanding between
the Russian Federation and the United
Nations
ultimately
participation in these agreements is a
choice
but struggling people everywhere and
developing countries don't have a choice
hundreds of millions of people face
hunger and consumers are confronting a
global cost of living crisis and they
will pay the price
indeed we are already seeing a jump in
with prices this morning
I am aware of some obstacles that
remained in the foreign trade of Russian
food and fertilizer products
and this is precisely why I sent a
letter to President Putin with a new
proposal to keep the Black Sea
initiative alive
in that letter which I believe is
necessary to quote at lens
I underline that and I quote
since the signing of the memorandum of
understanding and also taking into
account the measures adopted by the
Russian Federation
Russian grain trade has reached High
export volumes and fertilizer markets
are stabilizing with Russian exports
nearing full recovery as stated by the
Russian Union of grain exporters and
Russian fertilizer producers Association
end of quote
went on to detail action by the United
Nations namely that we have and I quote
also delivered breakthroughs even in
some of the most challenging areas of
trade facilitation
the United Nations has helped to secure
the issues of U.S general license 6B and
6c
which are especially important in light
of the extra territorial nature of U.S
sanctions as these licenses apply not
only to as imports from the Russian
Federation but also to all countries
concerned with their sanctions regime
two UK General licenses on finance and
trade in food and fertilizers
which are especially important for the
insurance Market
and the derogation by the European Union
in its nine sanctions package which
allowed for example the unfreezing of
assets of fertilizer companies as well
as a range of clarifications frequently
asked questions fact sheets and other
guidance to the private sector
these regulatory Frameworks as well as
extensive engagement with the private
sector to find dedicated Solutions
across Banking and insurance sectors
have led to the progressive
normalization of trading conditions
since July 2022
including declining fright and the
insurance rights
and bulk vessel Port calls at Russian
ports have also remained mostly steady
end of quote
the letter went on to detail how we have
built a bespoke payments mechanism for
the Russian agricultural Bank through JP
Morgan outside the Swift
and the letter also described how the
United Nations also has worth
closely with the key Russian fertilizer
groups to unblock assets amounting to
over 70 percent of the frozen assets in
the original list submitting To Us by
the Russian Federation in November 2022
and moreover the United Nations has
facilitated humanitarian donations of
fertilizers to most in need countries in
Africa overcoming profound complexities
of the operation
my letter mentioned
and I quote
the Russian Federation has highlighted
the issue of access to Swift by the
Russian agricultural Bank
as a key factor influencing is its
decisions
on this front the United Nations
recently brokered the concrete proposal
to enable a subsidiary of the Russian
agricultural Bank to regain access to
Swift
with the European Commission
the key element and repeating this
proposals political viability is that it
can be implemented within existing
regulations and we see this as a unique
political opening
stemming from a genuine desire to
protect Global Food security Beyond 17
July end of quote
I'm deeply disappointed that my
proposals went and heated
today's decision by the Russian
Federation will strike a blow to people
in need everywhere
but it will not stop our efforts to
facilitate any impeded access to global
markets for food products and
fertilizers from both Ukraine and the
Russian Federation
I particularly want to recognize the
efforts of the government of turkey in
these regards
looking ahead our goal must continue to
be advancing Global Food security and
Global Food price stability
these will remain the focus of my
efforts taking into account the rise in
human suffering that will inevitably
result from today's decision
we will stay fixed on finding Pathways
for Solutions
there is simply too much at stake in a
hungry and hurting worlds and I thank
you
thank you friends thank you very much
sorry this is